SRINI DEVADAS: All right
good morning, everyone.
Welcome back.
I hope you had a
good long weekend.
So today's puzzle is, I
guess, a classic puzzle.
It's Sudoku.
I've never actually
successfully managed
to complete a Sudoku
puzzle by myself,
because they've fallen
into two categories for me.
Either they're easy, and
I get bored and I stop.
Or they're too hard, and
I get lazy and I stop.
But what I have done is
write a computer program
that essentially solves
any Sudoku puzzle that is
put in front of it in seconds.
Maybe there exist puzzles for
which it would take minutes,
but I haven't
discovered such puzzles.
And what we're going to do
today is talk about Sudoku,
compare and contrast the human
way of solving Sudoku puzzles
against a brute force way,
and then try and integrate
the two together.
You know perhaps
this is the closest
we're going to get
to AI in this class,
where we're going to try and
marry an exhaustive search
method with some smarts.
And back-- I think when we were
doing the N-queens puzzle--
one of you asked a
question about what
the number of
possibilities were.
For an eight queens puzzle,
was it eight raised to eight?
And I said, well no.
You can prune the
search by figuring out
that particular partial
configurations that correspond
to perhaps two queens
being placed on the eight
by eight board already does
not correspond to a solution,
because the two queens
conflict with each other.
And you can then
shrink this eight
raised to eight substantially.
So that's exactly
the methodology
that we're going to
follow here in trying
to take our brute
force solver, which
will work, given enough time,
on arbitrary Sudoku puzzles.
But we may not want
to wait that long.
And we're going to take this
strategy of pruning the search
to try and improve the solver.
And one last thing before I get
started on the rules of Sudoku,
we're going to have to have a
way of measuring performance.
Just like we can measure eight
raised to eight or four raised
to four or what
have you, we want
to have a way of measuring--
outside of the
particular machine
that's being used,
we can obviously
measure real time
in terms of seconds,
but that's not as precise--
you want to measure
more precisely what
the number of combinations are.
And so we could certainly
instrument our code
with appropriate
counters that will allow
us to measure this performance.
And so then it won't matter if
our code runs on a fast machine
or a slow machine.
We can compare it with
another piece of code
or another variant of the code
and say, oh this new variant
is slower or the new
variant is faster
according to this metric.
All right?
So without further ado,
let's dive into Sudoku.
How many of you have never seen
Sudoku, never played Sudoku?
All right, so that's fine.
It's only going to take
me about 30 seconds
to explain what the
rules of Sudoku are.
And then we can dive into trying
to, at least partially, solve
this puzzle.
I do not want to
completely solve the puzzle
because, as I said, it's either
too simple or it's too hard.
And I'd rather write
computer programs.
And so the rules of
Sudoku are simple.
So this is classic Sudoku,
and it's a nine by nine.
There's many variants of Sudoku.
In fact, a couple
of the exercises
talk about two variants,
diagonal Sudoku and even
Sudoku, I think--
there's probably odd
Sudokus as well--
that add even more constraints
to the basic constraints
of Sudoku that I'm
going to write up here.
And this is nine by nine Sudoku.
And the numbers are
one through nine.
And the rules are simple.
Each row has all
the numbers, which
means that no numbers could
be repeated, because there's
nine columns and nine rows.
So there's nine
numbers on each row.
Each column has
all the numbers--
same thing.
So there's nine rows
and nine columns.
And then each sector, which
is a three by three grid--
and so that's why I have these
overhangs here corresponding
to pointing out what the
nine sectors are in Sudoku.
So this is a sector.
That's a sector.
This middle one, which
is completely blank
right now is a
sector, et cetera.
So each sector has
all the numbers.
You can grow the
size of the puzzle.
It gets more difficult. You
could add more constraints.
As I mentioned, diagonal
Sudoku might say something
like both of the diagonals, the
large diagonals, the full size
diagonals, have all nine
numbers on them, et cetera.
So that makes the
puzzle different.
You may have a
solution to the nine
by nine original Sudoku
puzzle, but it may not
be a solution to
the diagonal puzzle.
Obviously the other
way around works
because the diagonal puzzle
only has more constraints.
And so what we do here is
try and use implications.
Right, so we have these rules.
And we'll first forget
about computer programs
and try and solve this the
way people do when they just
have a paper and
pencil and they have
the puzzle in front of them.
And they try and use these rules
to discover empty positions.
And it's kind of hard to do
anything with this sector here.
You could use the row and
column constraints, obviously,
even for this sector.
Because you have constraints on
these three based on the fact
that you have nine and seven
and one and six on this row,
et cetera.
But usually you go
with sectors that
have a few numbers in them.
You go with rows that have
a few numbers in them.
And you go with columns that
have a few numbers in them.
And then you can try and
shrink the possibilities.
All right?
So just because I don't
want to go overboard
with respect to looking
all over the puzzle,
let's focus in on eight--
the number eight.
And one of you tell me
if I can imply something
based on the locations
of eight on the top third
of this puzzle.
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Top middle square.
SRINI DEVADAS: Top middle
square, what's your name?
Kye?
So Kye says top middle square
should be an eight, right here.
Right, and-- oh, top OK.
Yeah that clearly
can't be an eight,
because this is an eight here.
But good, so the claim
is this is an eight.
And Kye, how did
you figure that out?
AUDIENCE: You can eliminate
the first two rows because.
SRINI DEVADAS: Right
you can eliminate this,
because eight can't be
here because of this eight.
Eight can't be here
because of this eight.
You need to have an 8 in
here somewhere, because eight
doesn't exist in the sector.
So that would imply that I
need to put an eight up here.
OK?
So this is what's called
a horizontal scan.
The only thing that Kye did
here was scan horizontally.
And you can imagine that--
so Kye did not use, in
order to imply the eight--
and so this word implication,
imply, is something
that we're going to use
in a more technical sense
as well when we write our code,
but an implication essentially
says these rules imply
the location of the eight.
Right?
And we didn't do
a vertical scan.
We did not use the fact that--
in this particular
implication, we did not
use the fact that a column
needs to have all numbers on it,
and therefore all of the numbers
on a column have to be unique.
Take a look at--
take a look at this part here.
And let's look at one.
And try and use a more
sophisticated form
of implication corresponding
to both horizontal
and vertical scans to imply
the position of a one somewhere
on the puzzle.
Can someone do that?
Yeah, back there.
AUDIENCE: In the top box--
in the top right box,
it's to the right of six.
SRINI DEVADAS: OK, so
the one can't be here.
The one can't be here.
Right?
And the one can't be here.
So it has to be over here.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: George.
SRINI DEVADAS:
George-- so George
says the one has to be here.
And he used both vertical
scanning as well as
horizontal scanning in
order to imply the one.
So it's a little
more sophisticated.
OK, on top of that,
obviously, sectors
are going to give you
some implications as well.
And there's no end
to this, honestly.
There's combinations, there's
also a little bit of look
ahead, where the hardest puzzles
are the ones where you run out
of the eights and the ones
in terms of the examples
that we have here where
we've just sort of implied--
without guessing, we've implied
the location of a number.
And then because of that, our
puzzle got smaller in the sense
that there's fewer blank
locations, blank squares.
And then that helps
us move forward.
So the easy puzzles
are the ones where
fairly straightforward
implications
like the ones we did here
always exist, are easy to find.
Sometimes you have to search
a little bit, look at the top,
look at the bottom,
look at the middle.
And then you fill things in.
And because you
filled things in,
something else now
is in play, right?
It becomes viable in
terms of an implication.
The fact that I put
an eight in there
implies that the
eight is now taken--
its location.
And so now obviously
there's only four left here.
And the fact that
there's an eight here
implies that all of these
can't have an eight in them.
These seven locations
underneath can't
have an eight in them, right,
because of the constraints.
So this shrinking
of possibilities
is something that a human does.
And you can kind of go
through this process.
It's an iterative process
that you go through.
And if you get stuck then
you can't do an implication
that gives you a number.
And some of the harder
puzzles you have to-- you
have a couple of choices,
and only one of them
is going to be a correct
one going forward,
but you don't know
that at that moment.
So you now have to guess.
And perhaps you put
an eight over here
or an eight over there.
And then you say I'm going to
go with an eight over here.
And then you go a
little bit further,
and then you realize,
wait a minute,
there's no way I can
solve this puzzle.
Because I need to put two
sevens into this sector.
And then you go back and
there's actually a bit
of backtracking that happens--
a wrong guess, and you
need to go backwards.
And it's very hard to do for us.
It's very hard to do for
us with pencil and paper,
keeping things in our head,
or you know writing down notes
on the side of the paper.
Whereas it's very easy to do
that for a computer program.
And we kind of did that
already in the eight queens.
But we're going to do
that in a much more
systematic way over here.
So you kind of
weigh these two ways
of approaching this problem.
One of which is I'm
just going to blast
through the different
combinations,
having a giant tree
structure in my head of
where, you know this might imply
that particular grid location
grid IJ equals eight.
This might imply that
grid IJ equals seven.
And there's obviously
a huge number
of combinations corresponding
to which of these squares
that I pick and what value
I assign to those squares.
And then once I do that
there's another set.
And this explodes
on you very quickly.
And so if you just did this
in a completely brutish way,
there's no way your
program would ever
end, even on a simple puzzle.
But thanks to these rules,
it turns out a fairly
straightforward program that's
20 lines of code is going
to solve most problems-- at
least the ones that I've looked
at--
in a reasonable amount of time.
And then it's just interesting
from an algorithmic standpoint
and an efficiency
standpoint to look and see
how we can take that
fairly naive approach which
does have some pruning but it's
exhaustive and improve that.
All right, so that's kind
of where we are headed.
Make sense?
Any questions about
what we have so far?
All right.
So what we're going to
do is go ahead and look
at code for Sudoku that--
so all you need to think about
now for the next few minutes,
because we're going to move into
exhaustive search mode and code
things up in a computer,
is just those rules.
So you don't have
to really think
about horizontal scans and
implications or vertical scans.
That's going to come
a little bit later.
And we're going to
vary that up as well.
But we're going to do kind of
what we did for the N-queens
problem, which is set up
a recursive search that
is going to explore all of
these different possibilities.
And the equivalent of no
conflicts for the eight queens
or the N-queens problem, which
said there's no conflicts here
because none of the queens
attack each other, we're going
to have something that
essentially says this is valid
so far, none of
the rules of Sudoku
corresponding to
these three rules
that I have up on the board
are going to be violated.
All right so let's take a look.
And so this structure hopefully,
given that we've done N-queens,
should be a little bit
easier to understand.
So when we did eight
queens or N-queens,
we decided to start
column by column.
And we could have
done row by row,
but we decided to
start column by column.
And it was a fairly
straightforward puzzle.
There's obviously no real change
in an eight queens puzzle.
I mean, you're solving
the same puzzle as I am.
But if I give you
a Sudoku puzzle,
there's more variety
to it in the sense that
depending on what I fill up--
the hard puzzles
are the ones that
are kind of intermediate in the
sense of they're not obviously
fully filled and
they're not empty.
Right if it's
completely empty then
it's trivial to solve
a Sudoku puzzle.
You can take any solution
to a Sudoku puzzle
and present it as a solution
to the empty puzzle.
And then if everything is
full except for two things,
I mean it's kind of
obvious what those two
things are assuming that the
puzzle had a valid solution.
So really it's puzzles
like this where
maybe a third are full
that are more difficult.
And it's kind of a separate
school, a little community that
designs puzzles and tries
to create hard puzzles.
And they try and make
the human's problem
harder by making this
requirement of look ahead,
like I mentioned.
So good.
So let's take a look
at the code here.
So what I want to do here--
and the first part here is--
as I said, we went column by
column in the case of N-queens.
And the question is,
where do I start.
I want to do something
in a fairly naive way.
And what I'm going to do is I'm
going to do some sort of scan.
I'm going to scan like that.
And I'm going to find--
as I do the scan, I'm going
to find the next empty grid
location.
And I'm going to say that is
going to be something that I'm
going to try and fill in.
OK so it's not going to be I
discovered this eight in the--
it was, if you count in
terms of the empty locations,
if I went this way, it was
the fourth empty location
and decided to fill that up.
But here I'm just--
in this code I'm
going to try one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven, eight,
nine here.
And the first part
of the code here that
says what is the name
of this procedure.
It says find next cell to fill.
Which means what its name is--
find the next cell.
Find the next grid
location to fill.
And it simply goes
for X in range zero
through nine, for Y in
range zero through nine.
I'm assuming that since zero
is not a valid entry here,
I could use zero
to signify empty.
OK?
It's only one through nine,
so zero can signify empty.
And this just returns
X and Y corresponding
to the first empty location.
So in this case it
would just return (0,0).
OK?
And then if this were
full then it would go--
obviously the X changes.
And when X changes, you're
going over to the right.
And so you would
get a (1,0) back.
If this were filled,
the next time around I'd
get this grid
location, et cetera.
It doesn't matter.
Just like I could go
column by column or row
by row, as long as I
have a deterministic way
of discovering the
empty location--
and usually you want to have
the same way of discovering
the empty location.
But even that is
not a requirement
as long as there's
an empty location
and your find next cell to
fill finds that empty location
and returns it to you, you're
good, and the rest of our code
is going to work.
But no reason to
get more complicated
than what I have up there.
So find next cell
to fill makes sense?
We good with that?
All right.
And generally with
exhaustive search
the key procedure is always
do you have a valid solution
or not?
And you may not have
a complete solution.
Think of it as a
partial configuration.
So this is a partial
configuration that is valid.
It's not a complete solution
to the Sudoku puzzle.
It's a partial configuration
that's valid in the sense
that it satisfies all
of the constraints.
You know, if I put
another eight in here
it would not be a valid
partial configuration.
It would be partial,
but not valid.
Right?
I need to grow this.
I need to grow this
into a solution.
And when I say solution I
mean all the constraints
have to be satisfied.
A configuration could
be invalid or valid.
A solution is always valid.
All right?
That's just terminology.
And so I want to be
able to look high up
and be able to truncate
the search and say,
you know what, grid
IJ equaling eight,
because I put an eight in
that sector which already
had an eight in it, is something
that should not be explored.
And I don't have
to worry about any
of the branches that come here.
Because immediately I've
violated the constraint.
So in general, I
can always check
whether partial configurations
violate the three
constraints I have or not.
And that is what this
piece of code does.
And it's also straightforward.
It's perhaps even
more straightforward
than diagonal checking in
the case of eight queens.
But all this does is
use the construct that
says I'm going to look at--
essentially this is
something that is
list comprehensions in Python.
The for comes after
this predicate here.
But effectively what you're
saying is for X in range nine,
check that grid IX is
not equal to E. OK,
and you're just looking at E.
So is valid, grid IJE takes the
grid which looks like this one,
let's say, and so it's got zeros
in all of the empty places.
And it's got a bunch of non-zero
entries in all of the places
that you see here.
And in addition, you
have perhaps zero, zero,
and let's call it one.
And so this is I, and this
is J, and that is E. OK.
And so let me write that
out here, I, J, and E,
where I is one--
zero, I'm sorry, I is zero,
J is zero, and E is 1.
So that would mean
putting a one up here
and that obviously is going to
violate one of our constraints.
But that's fine.
We're going to check that.
And it's essentially
doing incremental checking
just like we did.
So it's not checking to see
that all of the existing grid
IJ values are
conflicting or not.
It's just saying I have an--
I'm going to be writing
something into this grid,
into an empty location.
It happens to be zero,
zero having the value one.
And I'm going to check
whether the introduction
of a one into this square is
going to cause problems or not.
That's all that it's doing--
incremental, just like
we had with eight queens.
And that check is
relatively easy to do,
because I just need to go and
I look at the row corresponding
to I, which in this
case is the top row.
I look at the
column corresponding
to J, which is the
leftmost column,
and then I look at the
sector corresponding
to zero, zero, which is
this top left sector.
And I check to see for
each of those three things,
whether there's
a problem or not.
And the first two--
well actually, I have
a problem with the row.
And I would also have a
problem with the sector.
I wouldn't have a
problem with the column.
But one of them is bad enough.
And so I'm going to get a false.
So row OK is going to be false.
And so I'm going to
return false out here.
All right, that make sense?
So those are the three things.
And there's really
not that much here
beyond taking those
constraints and codifying them.
Right.
Any questions?
Yeah.
Fadi.
AUDIENCE: What is
the all thing--
SRINI DEVADAS: Ah,
the all is essentially
a Python built in
function that is
going to essentially say that--
it's going to-- it's
a conjunction that
says I'm getting a bunch
of Booleans that correspond
to the generation of
this list comprehension
where E not equal to grid IX is
going to give me true or false.
And I need all of those
things to be true.
All right?
AUDIENCE: Okay, it's always
going to be a Boolean there
and that depends on
whether all of the elements
of the list itself are--
SRINI DEVADAS:
It's a conjunction.
Yeah, that's right.
So and, think of it as an and.
Even if one of them is
false, the and is false.
In order for the and to
be true, then all of them
need to be true.
All right?
So it's just a convenient
construct which
is applicable in sort of--
the perfect application
is what you see here.
It's not the most
sophisticated of applications,
but it works very
well in this case.
Now for the sector, I
can't actually do that.
And so there's a little bit
more work, because I can't--
this only works
when-- and I could
put a list comprehension
in here like this
and generate all the Booleans.
For the sector I end up having
to do something a little bit
different.
I mean you could do things more
convoluted and use all in here
as well, but it's not worth it.
OK, that make sense?
Good.
So here's the core routine
that corresponds to the search.
And ignore this
global variable here.
I'll explain that in a minute.
That's going to be our metric.
Backtracks is going to be
our metric for computing
performance.
And it's going to be
quite interesting.
It's going to produce some
interesting results for us
when we run this on
various different examples.
But this core
procedure looks a lot
like the n-queens
search in the sense
that you have a for loop
and a recursive call.
And in this case the
for loop is going
to be something that ranges
through the different values,
that you find a location that
you want to put something into,
which is the next empty location
in your current configuration.
And then you need to go put
in one through nine in there.
And it's brutish.
You're going to put
in one and you're
going to check conflicts.
And then you'll put
in two and you're
going to check conflicts.
If you put in a one and
you don't get a conflict,
then you get to recur.
And you now move
into something that
is another partial
configuration, potentially,
but obviously has
one location filled
from the caller configuration.
And then you go and
look for the next cell.
So it's certainly
possible that I'd go--
when I put in a one here that
fails, but if I put in a two
here, it's not going to fail.
A two is not going to fail
here because, if I just look
at those constraints, a two OK.
All right, so I'm going
to put in a two here.
And then I'm going to recur.
And I'm going to go out here,
and I'll try and put in a one
here.
And a one is going to fail
because of this and that.
A two is going to
fail because of that.
A three-- is a
three going to fail?
No, not immediately.
So I could put in a three here.
And then I recur and
go to the next one,
and so on and so forth, right?
And for each of these
things obviously
I have to do a bunch
of search underneath.
And you know thank goodness
for fast computers, right?
Because otherwise,
I mean God, I mean
can you imagine
the amount of paper
we'd generate if you were doing
this and putting two and three
and I want a new sheet
of paper for the four,
et cetera, et cetera.
I mean, we can count the
number of backtracks.
That's how many sheets
of paper you'll need.
OK.
So what you see here, again
ignore the backtracks,
I'll get to that in just
a second-- it's just
a way of counting
the number of calls.
And this thing here
essentially says
I'm going to be returning--
as long as I get through
and find a solution
I want to return true.
So if solve Sudoku
grid IJ is true,
then I'm going return through.
And then I'm going to pop
up all the way to the top,
assuming I got--
I go all the way down to the
bottom and I get to the point
where I have a solution
that returns true,
which is a completely
full configuration that
returns true.
Right?
But if not, then I need to
go try the other combinations
and I'm only going to
make that recursive
call if, obviously IJE,
corresponding to this,
is valid.
And that checks the constraints.
And the only other thing
I have to worry about
is essentially something that
says reset your grid location
and make sure that
you're setting it back
to zero after you're done.
Right, and so I've just
made a choice here,
grid IJ equals E. If I look
at this line of code here,
this is resetting the grid IJ
equals E and saying it's empty.
Because if I've
failed in all of these
and I haven't return true in
all of these, then obviously I
want to change this.
And you could argue that
the next time around
if I and J are
exactly the same--
because I and J
are set up here--
then I'm going to overwrite
the E from a one to a two,
et cetera, et cetera.
And so that is,
in fact, correct.
But I do need to reset
this outside of the loop,
if not inside of the loop.
So it's not like I can get
away with this line of code.
In general, if you
ever backtrack,
you have to go back
and undo your decision.
And you have to erase the tree.
And that's essentially what that
grid IJ equaling zero is doing.
You just need to
undo that decision.
And you can do this
a few different ways.
But the biggest
thing to remember
when you do recursive
search is to get your--
the undoing of your
decision, which
is what we call
backtracking, to be correct.
And if you ever leave a mess,
then you'd have a problem.
That's also true in the case
of the N-queens problem.
So I'm going to go ahead and--
and this is just
a print routine.
So this is not exactly the
Sudoku that I have up there,
the Sudoku puzzle
that I have up there,
but it's kind of roughly
similar in complexity.
And I could go ahead and
run the Sudoku program.
And for each of those
different Sudoku problems,
it's producing solved puzzles.
So this is a solved puzzle.
You can check this
puzzle just real quick
and you'll find that all of
the constraints are satisfied.
And I'm going to explain
backtracks in a second.
So true says that
there's a solution.
The number of
backtracks was 579.
For the second puzzle, which
was a little bit harder,
the number of
backtracks was 6363.
I'm sorry, this
is just scrolling.
And for the fourth
one, it was 335,000--
I'm sorry, for the third one.
And for the fourth
one, was 9949.
These last two
puzzles, hard and diff,
there was a Finnish guy called--
there is a Finnish guy
called Arto Inkala,
who designs puzzles.
And he claimed that
this hard puzzle in 2006
was the hardest puzzle
ever designed in Sudoku.
And then in 2010 he came up
with this more difficult puzzle,
according to him, that
required a lot of look
ahead from a standpoint
of the human being.
Like if we went back to
what I said you can't quite
do this implication.
You have to kind
of make a guess.
And then you have to go
further and further down.
And I think the claim was
that the hard puzzle required
like five levels of look ahead,
and then the difficult puzzle
required six levels
of look ahead.
And obviously, given
that look ahead,
this puzzle has to have an
initial configuration that's
solvable.
So it's not a trivial
thing to create puzzles.
But now people are
using computer programs
and doing things
like we're doing here
to find difficult puzzles.
And interestingly
enough, the 2006 puzzle,
at least for this
naive computer program,
takes 335,000 backtracks--
the one that was supposedly
made more difficult
in 2010, which now takes
about 10,000 backtracks.
So obviously there's a
difference between the way
this program behaves and
how you or I would behave,
or rather you would behave if
you tried to solve this puzzle.
So let me just
explain backtracks,
and then I'll stop
to see if there's
any questions about the code.
So when you make
recursive calls and you
want to count the number of
recursive procedure calls--
you want to do
something inside each
of the recursive
procedures and you
want to sort of cumulatively
or collectively keep
some information, one
way of certainly doing
it is to pass arguments.
And then you have to
return the argument,
because when you
pass an argument
and you modify it
it's not like that
is going to be--
that modification,
if it's just an integer, if
it's not a mutable variable,
it's not going to be seen
by the caller procedure.
And so when you do recursion and
you want to do some counting,
the notion of global variables
is a convenient construct
to have.
And global variables
essentially say
that there's exactly one
memory location associated
with this variable.
And we're going to
go ahead and, anytime
we are mutating this variable
and you're modifying it,
you're going to see the
effect of that in that memory
location.
So what you have up here is,
I set backtracks to be zero.
OK and that's my
global variable.
The fact that I put
backtracks equals zero
here doesn't make this a
global variable just yet.
The fact that I have global
backtracks inside of solve
Sudoku now says that there's
a single copy of backtracks,
and it doesn't
matter whether I'm
at the top level of recursion or
the bottom level of recursion.
It's just that memory location
corresponding to backtracks--
the name backtracks, that
is getting incremented.
And this could be
10 levels deep.
It could be 40 levels deep,
given that I've called things
40 levels in.
But it's just the
one backtracks.
So as you can see,
what backtracks does
is anytime you have
a valid location
and you've gone ahead and--
essentially you've failed.
The reason it's
out here is solve
Sudoku did not return true.
When solved Sudoku
actually returns false,
that's when you come out and
you increment backtracks.
So it meant that you
had to do some undoing.
When you set grid IJ to be
zero, that's when you're
undoing your guess, right?
So backtracks makes sense
from a standpoint of I
need to backtrack and go in
a different fork in the road.
And so that's why I have
backtracks plus equals one
when I'm undoing my
decision that I made.
So this kind of
gives you a sense
for how many wrong guesses
that this program did.
And as you can imagine,
the more the number
of wrong guesses, the more
the computation and the longer
it takes.
So it is definitely a
proxy for performance.
But it's a platform
independent proxy
that's more algorithm
related as opposed
to the speed of the computer.
Because if this computer
were twice as fast,
I mean I'd just see
things running faster
even though the algorithm
isn't any better.
Right?
That make sense?
So it's a very
simple use of global.
You don't want to
use global variables
except in certain
constrained settings.
This is a fine use
of global variables.
Cool, good.
So any questions
about this code?
So what I've done here is
I just have the naive code.
And I happen to have different
numbers of backtracks
because I have different inputs.
Unlike the N-queens
problem, which
is kind of boring in some sense,
because once you've solved it
there's nothing left,
in the case of Sudoku,
I could change my input,
my starting point,
and give you different problems.
And so the reason we had many
different kinds of backtracks
was simply because--
numbers of backtracks
was because we
had four different inputs
to the Sudoku puzzle.
All right, so are we good here?
People understand this code?
You're going to have
to modify it, right?
Not necessarily this code,
depending on the exercise
you do, but this is
certainly something
that hopefully you feel
comfortable with potentially
modifying.
All right so what I'm
going to do now is first
I'm going to go
ahead and show you
some code that corresponds
to something that
is the original
code, except that I'm
going to add some smarts to it.
What I'm going to do is,
at any given point of time,
I'm going to try to do some
implications without actually
doing any guessing.
So the way I'm going to
integrate the human approach
into this exhaustive search
approach at top level,
is I'm going to take
my configuration,
and before I do an
arbitrary guess,
before I call find
next cell, or maybe I
have a particular location
here that I'm eventually
going to guess.
So I do know that.
But before that, I'm
going to try and see
whether the current grid values
imply anything or not by using
the rules in exactly the same
way or roughly, I should say,
the same way that we did right
when we began the lecture.
All right?
So we're going to try
and use some implications
and maybe imply the eight
or imply something different
associated with
some other location.
So this is not a
backtrack, in the sense
that this is going to be--
I can take this to
the bank assuming
I haven't done any guessing
up until this point,
and assuming that the
initial configuration that
was given to me corresponds
to a valid solution.
But I'm actually
going to do this
at different points
in the search.
So it might be that I'm just
going to arbitrarily choose
a two here.
And so I go through and
I'm going to take this,
for argument's sake, and
I'm going to put a two down.
And then I have not the initial
puzzle that was given to me,
but something that I've
kind of hacked in the sense
that I've stuck a two in there.
And that may not
correspond to the solution,
because I just sort of
put the two down there.
But now given the two,
I'm going to try and do
some implications.
And I'm going to try
and see whether there's
things that are valid or not.
The important thing is that,
because I put a two down
in an arbitrary way
without using implications,
the two could have
been incorrect.
I mean that's exactly why we
have all of these backtracks,
correct?
Because I've put down
incorrect guesses and then
I've had to backtrack.
So once I put a
two down and then
I fill in a bunch of
things with implications.
You know, I may even
put an eight up there.
I may put a six out here,
et cetera, et cetera.
And I go deep in and
then I realize, ooh,
you know that two was a mistake.
The two really shouldn't
have been in there.
Now I have to clean
up everything.
I have to clean up all of the
guesses that came after two
and all of the implications
that came after two.
All right?
That's the biggest thing
that I want you to take away
from this integration
of implications
with exhaustive search.
It's clean up your mess,
clean up your bad guesses.
The fact that-- you say, oh but
the implication was something
that was deterministic.
It was exactly
following these rules.
No, no, no, no, no.
It was deterministic.
All of that is true.
But you made a wrong guess.
And therefore everything
that you did from then on out
is in question.
And if you, in fact,
find a contradiction,
you've got to go all the way
back and clean up everything.
And then go back and erase
everything that you had.
And then go take this two and
maybe turn it into a three
or what have you.
All right?
So before I show you the code
that does the implications--
and you can kind of
imagine that there's
many ways that we
could do implications,
we did that manually.
I want to show you this part
looks exactly the same as
before, no change.
Find next cell to grid
is exactly the same.
Is valid is exactly
the same, right?
There's a large make
implications procedure
and an undo implications
that I'll get to in a second.
But this part here looks
almost exactly the same,
except that I've
replaced grid IJ equals
E with make implications.
And this is something
that not only is--
what make implications is going
to do is it's going to set--
whatever I had up here, it's
going to set two up here.
And on top of that it's going
to go use these things to go
fill in a bunch of
different values in here.
So it's one extra step.
This is the integration
that I talked about.
So the idea is that--
now you can do this for
the original as well.
But the point is, once
you've made a guess,
you always want to check to
see whether that guess does
certain implications or not.
Right?
I mean that's the whole
purpose of this exercise.
Even humans do this in the
very difficult puzzles.
They make a guess and then
they see whether there's
some implication or not.
And maybe there's
a contradiction
and they have to go back and
undo all of that damage they
caused and change the guess.
But in general, when
you have a configuration
and you add to it,
it's possible suddenly
that there will be other things
that are implied by the one
change that you made to it.
So grid IJ equals E
in the original code
got replaced with this
procedure that we'll talk about,
which I don't want to spend
a whole lot of time on,
but it's essentially
something in terms of details.
But it's essentially
something that
puts in different values
in the different locations.
And grid IJ equal zero is
replaced by undo implications,
which is cleaning up all
of the incorrect guesses
and incorrect implications.
And the reason the
implications are
incorrect-- because it came
from an incorrect guess.
And so that's it.
Undo implications is trivial.
It just sets all of
the implications,
and I'll tell you what the
data structure is in a second,
but think of it as making
everything zero, going back
to a clean slate.
I mean clean slate
in the sense that all
of the incorrect implications
and guesses are cleaned up.
So that's all
there is over here.
Make implications is-- you
can do anything you want.
You can do vertical scans.
You can do horizontal scans.
You can-- if you go look
at Sudoku literature
and you look at ways
of playing Sudoku,
there's books written on
how you can become a better
Sudoku puzzle solver.
And you could take that,
and you could code that in.
And you could replace
make implications
with those fancy techniques
that are up there, right?
But we've established I'm lazy.
And so I only write a
certain amount of code,
and then I get tired.
And so I wrote about 20
lines of code corresponding
to a fairly straightforward
implication just
to give you a sense of
how this would work.
But the most important
thing in here
is not the details
of make implications.
And I'll give you some sense
of that before we're done.
But it's really the structure
that is the most important.
The fact that I've done make
implications here and undo
implications here is the
correctness requirement
that is important to
exhaustive search.
So if I do this and I do
kind of the implications
that we had right at
the beginning of lecture
and I go ahead and run
it, just take a look.
I won't write this
out, but remember
what the backtracks are for
these things, roughly speaking,
for the original Sudoku.
Oh, I'm sorry, I need
to go to the shell.
And it was 335,000--
what is it-- 579, 6363,
335,000, and 9949.
So if I go off and I
run Sudoku optimized,
which is doing these
implications like I describe,
and I go ahead and run that.
The first one goes from
579 to 33 backtracks.
OK so that's pretty good.
Because it's done a
bunch of implications.
It's still-- it's
not super smart.
I mean that is a simple enough
puzzle that a human being would
not backtrack.
I mean a human being would not
backtrack in that first puzzle,
right?
And you should check that.
And-- oh, this thing
finished in the middle.
So it went to 33.
Oh, only had three of them?
What do I have
here in Sudoku Opt?
Oh I see.
I only ran-- oh wow.
OK so I ran inp2,
hard, and difficult.
So it really went
from 6363 to 33.
It went from 335,000 to 24,000.
And then it went to--
7-- went from 9949 to 726.
The details aren't-- the
numbers aren't super important.
Don't hang your hat on them.
Obviously if I change the
code those numbers change.
But you can see that there
are substantial gains
to be had in terms
of implications
not making these dumb guesses
that clearly are incorrect.
And you can fill
in-- if you take away
some of these
empty squares, then
the depth of the recursion
that you have to go through
becomes substantially smaller.
And that's why your
backtracking is simpler.
So I want to leave you
with a couple of things.
I want to give you some sense
for what particular implication
that--
a strategy that we used.
And so I'll just put up make
implications and give you
some sense for how this works.
So the basic idea is
that what I'm doing here
is I'm looking at a
particular sector.
And I've created a data
structure that says the missing
elements here-- if I
put a two in here--
let's just say I go ahead
and put a two in here.
The missing elements here are--
the set is three, four,
five, six, seven, and nine.
So this could be three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine.
This could be three, four,
This is quite dumb right now.
But each of these
different squares
could be three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine.
OK?
Possibly, all right.
And then I say-- so that's
the first part of the code.
And then I say I'm going
to attach, essentially,
a copy of the set to each
of the missing squares.
And then I'm going to go through
and find the missing elements.
So this thing here can't be a
nine because I see a nine here.
It can't be a three, right?
And so I can take
this thing here.
And I take away the nine.
And I take away the three.
And I can do the
same thing with that.
Obviously I can
also take away the--
the eight isn't there, but
I could take away the seven,
and I could away the three,
the six, and the one.
So I go ahead and I
take away the six.
And the three was
already taken out.
And I keep doing this.
And I try and shrink the
possibilities corresponding
to this particular
square that has the set
of different possibilities.
And if I ever--
so when can I make
an implication?
What is the condition
that is going
to let me make an implication
when I take this set of numbers
and I start shrinking them down
using these rules that I have
over on the right
hand side there?
What is an implication?
What does that correspond
to in relation to the size--
in relation to the set?
Right, yeah, behind you, Ryan.
AUDIENCE: So if you
only have one element.
SRINI DEVADAS:
That's exactly right.
If you have one
element in the set,
then that's an implication.
If I have two
elements in the set,
it's not an implication,
because I don't quite
know what to do there.
But if I had one element in
the set, that's an implication.
And that's it.
That's-- you know this
code is not complicated.
Check if the vset is
a singleton, which
is a single element.
And I'm going to
go ahead and append
to this implication, which is
a very straightforward data
structure that says this
is the grid location I,
grid location J, and this is the
value that was implied by that.
So not only do I have IJE,
which is the original guess
that I have, I also have kind
of a bunch of other tuples
corresponding to
different coordinates,
you know, KL coordinates
and the value, call it V,
associated with that.
And these are all the
different implications
that I can collect
together in this list.
And I can just add those
things into make implications.
And then I keep going.
And then if I ever realize
I've made a bad guess,
I have to undo everything by
zeroing them all out, which
is making them all empty.
So one thing that
this code does,
and you can take a look at it.
And I would encourage you to
do the first exercise, which
is taking these implications
and making them a little more
powerful by adding three or
four lines of code to this code.
And exactly what you have
to do in this exercise,
and I'll show you what
the results should
be in just a minute.
But let me just spend 30
seconds explaining to you
how you could do a
little bit better
than what this code does.
So what I've described to
you really is get this set,
imply, get a
singleton, et cetera.
And then you can
do this, obviously,
for each of these sectors.
And that's what this does.
You had a for loop
up there that does it
for each of the sectors.
Grab a sector and
go ahead and do
an implication for that sector.
Now this code just runs
through the sectors,
you know, One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine
and then discovers
the implications
if they exist, adds
them to the imply list,
and then throws up its hands
and says I'm tired, I'm done,
I don't want to do any more.
What could you do that's
an improvement, given
what we have described and
what I've told you so far.
What is an incremental
improvement
over going over
these sectors once
and doing these implications
and storing them and moving on?
What is an incremental
improvement?
Ganatra?
AUDIENCE: Look, once we
get all the singletons,
we can set those as-- since
those are determined, like,
deterministic, I think
that we could set those
into the original grid and
say that's our new base grid
and run through it again.
SRINI DEVADAS: Run
through it again, exactly.
You don't have to stop.
There's no reason to
stop if you're implying.
Once you've put
something in here
and you've gone through one,
two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine,
got the implications,
you can put them into the grid
and then start over again.
One, two, three, four,
that's what humans do.
Right?
When humans put something
in, then they don't stop.
They just keep going
until they get to the end.
Now of course all of
these implications
could be incorrect if that
first guess was incorrect.
There's no change there.
But there's nothing
that's stopping you
from turning this little thing--
there's a loop here that simply
corresponds to making a
pass over the sectors,
but you can put this
whole thing into a loop.
And you keep going
through the loop
until you basically
have no change that
happens in your grid.
OK so that's four lines of code.
And I'm not going to show you
what those four lines of code
look like, so close
your eyes in case you--
And this is the
solution to that code.
And I'm going to go
ahead and run it.
And you saw what those
numbers were with respect
to the backtracks.
But if you do those
extra implications,
the 33 went down to
two for that example.
So this is not optimal,
because I wanted one.
So if I wanted to be
a human being that
took this easy puzzle
and just sort of went
all the way without making
any incorrect guesses,
I would be doing implications.
And that would go all the way.
And I got close with two.
And I didn't print out
the intermediate ones,
but the 24,000 went
down to 11,000.
And I forget what
the last one was.
It went down.
So with four lines of code
and with the optimized code
that I'll put up you should
be able to get those numbers
in your first exercise.
Or you could solve diagonal
Sudoku or even Sudoku.
Or you could spend the
rest of the day coding
whatever you want, whatever.
All right, see you next time.